welcome back to new rock stars i'm erik
voss and spider-man no way home's latest
surprise is the way the spider-verse
villain seemed to be getting an mcu
makeover not just with the marvelous
de-aging technology but as if kevin
feige looked them all up and down and
said i'll tell you what throw a little
hot rod red in there dr octopus is
confirmed to have acquired the stark
tech nanotech from peter's iron spider
armor so the question is how given that
doc ock's arms were built in a separate
universe seemingly without tony stark
and his technology and is this transfer
something dock intended to happen or
something happening outside of his
control i'm gonna break down the
technological history of this nanotech
why exactly it's so seamlessly
compatible with doc ock's arms and what
this union between octavius tech and
stark tech tells us about a possible
link between these two great thinkers as
these worlds are colliding let's start
by breaking down the timeline of the
visuals from the release footage so far
in the earlier stages of the bridge
battle otto attacks peter who suits up
with this iron spider armor with otto
using his dock arms from the 2004 films
the titanium steel segmented arms and
claws controlled via a busted neural
link fused into his spinal cord
mistaking this peter for his toby
maguire peter he says hello peter do i
know you
you think your fancy new suit's gonna
save you and after coiling peter in the
arms and clawing at his head peter seems
to break free using his own golden
mechanical arms in auto response looks
like we got competition after which both
of them end up beneath the bridge where
the red nanotech spills onto otto's arms
and peter you'll notice is left with
less than 100 of his nanotech and has to
transfer his helmet nanobots to his open
chest region at the last second and we
know he's not totally successful because
his necktie later appears severed and
during this transference doc ock looks
surprised however i don't think peter is
intentionally spreading his nanites onto
doc in order to restrain him like a kind
of handcuff maneuver as some of you have
suggested because even after having the
red nanobot spread onto his arms under
the bridge doc ock restrains and attacks
peter again from that point forward and
during this moment peter says i am so
confused right now so peter's confused
doc ock is confused who's doing the
transference i think the claws
themselves but really the confusion
comes in how these nanobots are lego
brick compatible with doc ock's arms if
he came from a different universe tony
stark's nanotech until now seemed to be
an invention unique to the mcu we
actually first saw him tinkering with
nanotech back in iron man 2 in a deleted
scene damn it i hate this thing my nano
ball i don't want to play with your ball
and then after civil war tony
successfully engineered a full nanotech
armored suit in the form of the iron
spider suit revealed at the end of
spider-man homecoming and in his own
mark 50 armor revealed in avengers
infinity war last year the wakandaphiles
book released by marvel confirmed that
tony was only able to complete these
nanotech suits after receiving notes on
nanotech from the wakandans and their
vibranium suit technology which
similarly spill out from a chest based
container so this history of nanotech
armor therefore would seem to be
specific to the mcu not to the rainy
trilogy continuity where doc comes from
but not so fast because if you go back
and re-watch the rainy trilogy films as
i have scouring them for spider-verse
crossover clues because i knew this day
would come there are actually quite a
few details included in those films by
sam raimi perhaps unintentionally but
nonetheless left the door open in a way
that no way home could totally use to
justify how doc ock's arms are now
compatible with mcu tech open doors that
we should never want to fix you'll get
your rent when you fix this damn door
yes obviously i've been staring at the
screen for a lot of this and if you're
like me and you spend a lot of your days
staring intently at screens you might
notice your eyes feel heavy and you have
problems sleeping well blue light
damages our eyes and leads to digital
eye strain symptoms of digital eye
strain include blurred vision headaches
dry watery eyes tendencies to see
mephisto everywhere and for some folks
this can even affect your energy level
well blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block out the blue light
with high quality lenses thanks to blue
blocks for sponsoring this video blue
blocks are evidence-backed and made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia the founders were unhappy with
the quality behind leading blue light
blocking glasses brand so they made
their own and they have over 40 styles
of frames and come in prescription
non-prescription and readers so they
have frames for every need and blue
blocks currently has their black friday
sale campaign running which is great
news for you all is you can save 25 off
all products until november 30th
ordering some of their great products
during this mega sale go to
blueblocks.com to save 25 today that's
blueblox.com
blublox.com and the 25 discount code is
automatically applied at checkout and
thanks again to blueblocks for
sponsoring today's episode so all the
way back in the first sam raimi
spider-man film there was an exchange
between peter parker and norman osborne
the first time they met and like all the
lines in those movies it's a moment you
probably know better as a meme i'm
something of a scientist myself i read
all your research on nanotechnology
really brilliant and you understood it
yes i i wrote a paper on it
depression i know i know i'm something
of a william to vote fanboy myself
norman osborne before leading up oscorp
as an executive board gladhand screamed
about how much he sacrificed he himself
was a tinkering engineer who pioneered
nanotech which yes in the context of
this film was more likely that referred
to any hardware saving microengineering
yet still evidence that oscorp possessed
some groundbreaking nanotechnology of
course norman osborne died before oscorp
hired otto octavius
that decision was made by harry osborne
when he took over in spider-man 2. but
it was clear that oscorp was fully
funding otto octavius's experiments
supplying him with all kinds of
resources down to the tritium fuel
supply i'd like to thank harry osborne
and ask corp industries for providing it
meaning it is possible that octavius's
smart arms were built using oscorp
proprietary hardware including norman
osborne's nanotech octavius built those
arms to be controlled by a neural link
fused into a spinal cord with an
inhibitor chip that kept his cerebellum
in control the arms but when the
accident fries that ship the arms take
over which the movie shows by turning
the white lights in the claws red not
until the end of the movie when the red
light flickers back white does otto
regain control of the arms spiderman no
way home is now clearly maintaining that
color scheme showing doc ock's claws
with glowing red lights meaning the arms
are still in control including the shot
of the red nanotech spreading on those
arms meaning it was the arm's decision
to absorb the nanotech not his in the
mcu the nanotech armor of the mark 50 in
the iron spider must be neurally
controlled because often iron man and
spiderman are able to activate functions
in that armor or at least have it
initially spill out over them without
any vocal command so that neural link
plus the nanotech compatibility gives
docock at least the technical capacity
now to absorb this stark attack but
beyond this there may also be a more
multiversal explanation to this
synchronization with jk simmons playing
alternate versions of j jonah jameson in
both the mcu and the raimi verse before
doctor strange's spell mixed anything up
that may be implying there are already
various parallels in place among these
separate universes before they spill
into each other you'll remember back in
the 2004 spider-man 2 jameson
brainstormed nicknames for doc ock in a
pitch session what are we going to call
this guy uh uh dr octopus that's crap
science squid crap
doctor strange that's pretty good
but it's taken a joke but also an
acknowledgment that in the rainy verse
exists a doctor named steven strange we
never saw doctor strange in the rainy
films so we don't know if he was
referring to the fact that he was just a
famous physician or a freaking wizard
you're a wizard harry
but if doctor strange can exist in this
alternate universe why not an engineer
named tony stark an alt universe tony
stark who might have even been
colleagues with auto octavius since if
you think about it both auto octavius
and tony stark and the mcu ended up
being focused on creating renewable
energy sources for public use as we saw
tony stark doing at the beginning of the
avengers film hooking up an electricity
hardwire at the bottom of the river
using his stark tower as a way to power
the entire city's grid so showing doc ox
arms already compatible with mcu stark
tech is just one little visual example
of how the mcu might plan to blend
elements and characters from previously
separate franchises into the framework
of the universe they've already built by
making these characters simply
unquestioningly familiar with mcu faces
in mcu tech by saying there's a version
of this and a version of you from where
i come from except where i come from
tony stark looks a bit more like tom
cruise and he is nuts
that's why you're here it doesn't have
to be tom cruise it could be anyone i'm
just giving an example but hey you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you